in the U.S four people have been killed
in a shooting in Louisville Kentucky
several others were injured it happened
inside a bank on a Main Street police
say the suspect was killed and that
there's no further danger to the public
confirmed to be dead on the scene we do
not know exactly the circumstances of
his death at this time
five people have been confirmed to have
been killed inside at least six were
transported to University of Louisville
Hospital including one officer with
various injuries we were unable to
confirm the status of those who have
been transported at this time I will
reiterate that this is an ongoing
investigation this information is
preliminary and it will be updated
shortly we ask that the public remain
Away From The Scene It will be an
ongoing scene that will take a long time
to investigate but there is no active
danger known to the public at this time
is following developments in Washington
D.C he joins us now live show how what
do we know about what happened
interestingly we're getting a rather
detailed timeline from from Louisville
Police which is interesting because
often you know the police have been
accused in the past are actually sort of
not being terribly Cooperative but let's
say look this occurred at 8 30 8 30 a.m
local time
that's about 12 30 GMT GMT at a bank in
downtown Louisville they say that within
three minutes of receiving the emergency
call they were on the scene and were
able to enter the building they
exchanged gunfire with the assailants
but that's why they're not sure how the
assailant died whether it was from that
exchange of gunfire or from a from a
self-inflicted wound we're getting some
eyewitness testimonial at least
testimony from those who spoke to those
inside the bank who say that many of
them just followed what is the bank
protocol in the event of a of a shooting
that is they press the panic button to
alert the authorities and then went to
hide in the bank vault obviously here in
the U.S those sorts of Protocols are
common in workplaces as you said 800 too
critically we understood about an hour
ago that those two critically injured
were being operated on
this is the 146th mass shooting of the
Year according to the gun violence
archive they've only been 100 days of
the year so far we are expecting another
update soon but as you can see perhaps
because of that very quick response time
the police are very a very open to being
very relatively transparent
about the shooting partly I think also
and even the governor mentioned it the
Louisville police are under a cloud
right now because just a few weeks ago
the Department of Justice
um found that they were they were guilty
of routine civil rights human rights
violations unconstitutional Behavior
she had returns it there live in
Washington many thanks indeed shahab